hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the prisoner's dilemma is a famous
problem in games theory and probably
many of you are already familiar with it
there are two prisoners and they have to
decide whether they engage in certain
actions not knowing what the other
prisoner is going to do when the
interaction of their choices is going to
produce certain outcomes and Peter
Singer in his biological basis of ethics
si is going to use this to try to argue
for why there would be a sociobiological
basis for reciprocal altruism so let's
let's talk about the nitty-gritty of the
problem first he brings up the classical
instance of it with the rear attained
Ian's secret police and the two
political prisoners and we can arrange
it like a two by two cell in which each
prisoner has the option of either
confessing and thereby implicating the
other prisoner or not confessing under
torture interrogation whatever it
happens to be and so we have four cells
because we have one where neither
confesses we have one where both confess
and then we have one where one confesses
and the other doesn't and another one
where the roles are reversed so he says
the prisoners know they know the
outcomes they know that if neither of
them confesses the police will not be
able to make the charge stick but they
will be interrogated in the cells for an
um another three months before the
police give up and let them go so if
neither confesses they actually get the
best outcome overall if you think about
the total aggregate each of them gets
three months each of them loses
essentially one quarter of a year but he
says if one of them confesses
implicating the other the one who
confesses will be released immediately
they go free they have no penalty
whatsoever but the other will be
sentenced to eight years in jail so
that's a pretty significant increase in
the
amount of time you can see why there
would be an incentive there to turn in
your fellow prisoner to confess and let
the burden fall upon them what happens
if both of them confess well then they
both get five years which is not a good
outcome right and actually the both
confess if you think about it in terms
of the aggregate it's the worst
altogether because it's ten years total
in the case of one of them confessing
and the other one not it's pretty bad
but you get to shift the burden entirely
on to the other person or if you happen
to be the sucker who behaved
altruistically while the other person
behaved egoistically that is selfishly
you get stuck with the 8-year burden so
that's the classical framework of the
problem and singer points out something
that you know is not unique to him of
course this is often used to demonstrate
the problems of egoism so he says that
each prisoner could ask themself this
this sort of line of reasoning well if
the other prisoner confesses it'll be
better for me if I've also confessed
because then I'll get five years instead
of eight and the other prisoner if they
don't confess it'll still be better for
me because I'll get released immediately
instead of being interrogated for
another three months because we're
interrogated separately I don't know
what they're going to do their choice is
independent of mine so whatever happens
it will be better for me just me alone
if I confess so if you're this person
here in the side you know cell right
you're making these two choices then you
say well I'm going to confess because at
least then I go free and the other poor
bastard
is stuck there anything you know if we
both confess well then I you know I get
five years so he says the second
prisoner's self-interested reasoning
will follow the exact same route and
will come to the same conclusion so both
of them know the other person's
rationale and they can both say well you
know even if I don't confess that other
guy's going to confess so I better do it
so what's the outcome here if everybody
is egoistic if they're operating on pure
self-interest the rational thing to do
is to confess and then you end up with
the worst outcomes you can't do the
better strategy for both yourself and
for the the group if you're a purely
self-interested so he says well what
could change that
what could get us towards a better
solution to this he says one way of
achieving this would be for the
prisoners to make an agreement that
would bind them both to silence so
imagine they're being brought in and
they're both like we're gonna stick to
the story we never were at the political
meeting all right see you later
see in three months and neither one
knows what the other one's gonna do he
says how could each prisoner be
confident that the other would keep the
agreement if one prisoner breaks the
agreement the other is going to be in
prison for a long time
unable to punish the other prisoner
unable to impose any sanctions on them
they're getting away scot-free right so
how can I actually trust that the other
person is going to follow through on
what they said they can make a
commitment to me but you know as Thomas
Hobbes famously said you know words
without the sword are mere wind I
believe he said something like that I
maybe miss phrasing it but it's the same
idea you can't rely on a covenant or
agreement or pact unless there's some
way to enforce it so he says without
sanctions to back it up an agreement is
unable to bring two self-interested
individuals to the outcome that's best
for both of them what has to be changed
then well it's not by adding another
agreement we have to change the
motivations of these people if we can do
that then we can get a better solution
so like you says we have to change the
assumption that the prisoners are
motivated by self-interest alone if he
says for example they are altruistic to
the extent of caring as much for the
entry
their fellow prisoner as they care for
their own interests they will reason
thus if the other prisoner doesn't
confess will be better for both of us if
I don't confess because then we'll be in
total for prison for a total of six
months whereas if I do confess the total
will be eight years and if the other
prisoner does does confess it will still
be better if I don't confess that a
total served up to eight years instead
of ten so whatever happens
taking our interest together it'll be
better if I don't confess now notice he
doesn't say this has to be a altruistic
person in the sense of being totally
self-sacrificing you just have to care
as much about the other person's welfare
or outcomes as you do for your own and
if that's the case then the rational
thing for both people to do independent
of what the other person does not
knowing what the other person is going
to do is to not confess and to attain
the better position so altruism can help
us out of the prisoner's dilemma singer
says that's not the only way that we
could get ourselves out of the dilemma
says another possibility is that the
prisoners or what he calls conscientious
meaning that they regard it as morally
wrong to inform on a fellow prisoner or
if they're if they're able to make an
agreement they might believe they have a
duty to keep their promises in any case
there's something de ontological rather
than consequentialist going on there
they feel that once they've made an
agreement or you know that they're in a
situation like that the right thing to
do is to not confess and we don't worry
about what they're up you know their
reason for that obligation is it could
be that you know they've just been
brought up in a very strict code that
says outsiders we don't talk to them
doesn't matter that would lead them to
the same solution as the people who are
genuinely altruistic now what's the OP
shot for this we're not often in secret
prison cells thank goodness and actually
we're not usually in the situation that
singer is going to talk about you know
in this mythical past but let's look at
that so he says we we can use this to
explain and evolu
Machinery advantage and being genuinely
altruistic instead of making reciprocal
exchanges on the basis of calculated
self-interest suppose to early humans
are attacked by a saber-toothed cat
right and it doesn't have to be a
saber-toothed cat could be whatever you
like
could be a crocodile could be some you
know other terrifying thing what can
they do the the instead of being
confessing and not confessing it'll be
sticking around with your comrade and
fighting the thing or taking off if both
of them stick around and fight then
there is a chance that one of them will
get wounded but they'll probably Drive
the predator often they'll probably be
both okay if they both flee they don't
actually both come out bad because the
saber-tooth tiger is only hungry for you
know one belly full of person and we'll
get one of them fairly randomly if one
of them sticks around and the other one
doesn't that one who sticks around is
screwed they're gonna get killed by the
saber-tooth cat so there's the the the
structure of the dilemma he says from a
self-interested point of view if your
partner flees your chances are survival
are better if you flee to you have a 50%
chance rather than none at all and if
your partner stands and fights you still
do better to run you're sure of escape
if you flee whereas it's only probable
not certain that you and your partner
can overcome the cat so to purely
self-interest that early humans would
flee and one of them would die which is
you know bad fur for both Oh in the long
run really so he says to early humans
who cared for each other whether it be
again from altruism valuing the other
person's welfare equal to your own or
having some sort of moral code that
tells you what to do and makes you feel
bad if you don't do it either one of
those would lead to the better outcome
he says they would stand and fight and
most likely neither would die so he says
in if situations analogous to this
imaginary saber-toothed cat attack were
common early humans would do better hunt
with altruistic comrades than with
self-interested partners of course an
egoist who could find an altruist to go
hunting with him would do better still
but altruists who could not detect and
refused to assist purely self-interested
partners would be selected again so that
evolution itself would lead to people
who are prone to be altruistic and
support their partners at least when
confronted by danger so this is singers
analysis of the prisoner's dilemma as it
would apply to egoism and altruism
particularly reciprocal altruism in in
dangerous situations but I think it
could be applied to a lot of other
things as well and he's trying to argue
that this is something that's rooted in
our background in our evolution as the
kind of animal that we are
you